اسم النمسا ارتبط بكونها الجسر الحقيقي في
العالم بين الشرق والغرب هل ما زال الحال
كذلك
عشنا تحديات كثيره وحتى الوطن العالمه
تبقى فيا منصه للحوار والاجتماعات ونحن
كبار
باننا لازلنا الدوله
والعالم الذين نعيش فيه الان نحن بحاجه
الى ذلك اكثر من اي وقت سبق ربما سوره
البلد
لكننا ايضا لا نستطيع ان ننسى تاريخها
العظيمه وتاثيرها الكبير على تاريخ
البشريه بما في ذلك في الحربين العالمتين
هل يفسر هذا الارث الحذر الكبير في
السياسه الخارجيه فيما يتعلق بالملف
الاوكراني تحديدا
الويدوها
لدينا المسؤوليات المسؤوليه التاريخيه
وناخذها على محمل الجده مثلا عبر صداقتنا
وعلاقاتنا القويه مع اسرائيل ولكن سياستنا
الخارجيه ليست حذره بعدما ذكرت اوكرانيا
فهذا الوضع استريا او النمسا ليس وضعها
محايدا عندما نتحدث عن القيم وميثاق الامم
المتحده
فلا يمكن ان نبقى محايدين بل ناخذ موقفا
واضحا جدا
ولكننا نستمر بالقول باننا يجب دائما
نتمكن من الحوار الاوروبيه